the sanctions against russia have sent
its economy into freefall and brought
global condemnation of president putin
now the biden administration is
considering new sanctions that could
hurt consumers here at home natalie
brand is at the white house with the
very latest natalie good morning
good morning dana ukraine as we know has
pleaded for more help and the white
house has now asked congress for 10
billion dollars in emergency defense and
humanitarian assistance for the country
and this morning u.s senators have been
invited to a zoo meeting with ukraine's
president zielinski
we're committed to helping ukraine
defend itself at the white house friday
president biden talked security with the
president of finland a non-nato country
which shares an 800 mile long border
with russia the support for ukraine
is
real profound extensive secretary of
state anthony blinken in belgium for
emergency nato meetings warned that
russia's onslaught will likely get worse
fortunately this is not like flipping a
light switch
and president putin's russia
a country that is prepared to go to
excessive means to achieve its results
friday russian troops attacked europe's
biggest nuclear power plant in
southeastern ukraine sparking worldwide
fears of a catastrophe much worse than
chernobyl's nuclear accident in 1986.
there have been no reports of radiation
leakage but the u.s has called for
russian forces to withdraw from the
plant saying nuclear facilities cannot
be part of this conflict it was
incredibly reckless
and dangerous
and it threatened the safety of
civilians across russia
ukraine
and europe as economic consequences for
russia continue to expand the commerce
department announced new regulations
aimed at cutting off russia's oil
refineries from getting access to u.s
technology
and lawmakers across both sides of the
aisle are calling for a ban on russian
energy imports i'm all for that ban it
ban the oil ban the oil come from russia
yep this will be a significant blow to
putin's warship war machine the biden
administration says it's looking at
options to cut u.s consumption of
russian energy but worries about the
impact to consumers
if you reduce supply in the global
marketplace you are going to raise gas
prices
meanwhile vice president kamala harris
is scheduled to travel to europe next
week to visit romania and poland where
thousands of u.s troops are positioned
in support of nato a bipartisan
congressional delegation is also
visiting the region this weekend
visiting the border in poland jeff
natalie thank you very much